We know broken clocks can be right twice a
day, but they can be wrong for the, it can
be right for the wrong reason.
Better said.
And that's exactly what happened with Fox
news.
Propagandists Tucker Carlson, after the Trump
Iran fiasco got underway with the unauthorized
assassination of Iranian codes leader Kaseem
Solemani, Tucker Carlson correctly pointed
out maybe Iran is not the greatest threat
we face.
Maybe Americans wouldn't benefit from escalating
a war with Iran.
Maybe we have our own issues to deal with
here in the United States.
Now of course the issues, Tucker, things we
need to deal with in the United States are
very different from the issues you and I likely
think we need to deal with in the United States.
But Tucker has this sort of anti interventionists
side and he is correctly pointing out on Fox
news that this doesn't make a shred of sense.
Take a look.
Threats in the region.
If you don't live in Washington, here's the
translation that would be in hostile middle
Eastern countries, places where American Jews
would never be in the first place, where it
not for the insistent demands of non geniuses
like max boot and John Bolton, but nevermind.
No one in Washington is in mood for big picture
questions right now.
Questions the obvious ones like, is Iran really
greatest threat we face and who's actually
benefiting from this and why are we continuing
to ignore the decline of our own country in
favor of jumping into another quagmire from
which there was no obvious exit.
By the way, if we're still in Afghanistan,
19 years sad, years later, what makes us think
there's a quick way out of Iran and so on?
Nobody is thinking like that right now.
Instead, chest beaters like Senator Ben Sasse
of Nebraska are making unusual warlike noises.
The ones they always make.
This is very simple.
Ben Sasse wrote in a statement last night,
general Soleimani is dead because he was an
evil bastard who murdered Americans, which
is essentially true.
So Amani was certainly a bad guy, but does
that make killing him?
Quote very simple.
It does not.
Nothing about life and certainly nothing about
killing is ever very simple and any politician
tells you otherwise is dumb or is lying.
Yes.
Soleimani was linked to the deaths of Americans.
Nobody mourns his passing.
But Mexico and China are also linked to the
deaths of Americans.
Each has flooded our country with narcotics
from which tens of thousands of Americans
die every single year.
Not that anyone in power cares.
So does that mean we get to bomb Wahaca?
Can we start assassinating generals and the
people's liberation army?
Maybe.
Maybe Ben sassful call for that too.
He's a former consultant and a very tough
character.
Tucker Carlson is spot on that nothing will
be quicker, easy.
There will be no solving a problem by invading
Iran.
There will be nothing simple about assassinating
a leader like Kaseem Soleimani and saying,
Hey, great, we did it.
We have a horrible track record of being totally
unable to end conflicts that often make no
sense to begin with and Tucker Carlson agrees
with me and with many people that Kaseem Soleimani
was a bad guy, but the idea that we should
assassinate him and then escalate a military
conflict with Iran is a terrible idea.
There are right wingers who are experiencing
some cognitive dissonance here because they
see Trump really wants it, but another pseudo
hero of theirs.
Tucker Carlson doesn't want it.
What do we do?
This is where you need to be able to think
for yourself.
This is an authorized assassination which
if you believe in checks and balances has
to be opposed period.
This is the possible lead-up for political
purposes to another endless conflict, very
expensive one where the winners are military
contractors, the Warhawks, maybe Trump getting
reelected and the losers are all the people
that will die.
Americans who are seeing their tax money spent
on political conflicts rather than on improving
the United States.
Merely it's like we don't have to go look
for proposals for how to improve things.
We've got proposals on healthcare and education
and so many other things.
Even if you hate Iranian leadership and what
a ran stands for and the religious theocracy
that exists there, you still have to be against
this.
But then of course Carlson goes on to say,
we have our own issues, issues to deal with.
A lot of the issues he wants to deal with
are horrible examples of xenophobia.
Tucker Carlson has talks about, uh, the hoax
of white supremacy.
It's not a hoax.
It's a real issue we've got to deal with in
the United States.
He thinks it's fake.
Tucker has talked about how immigrants coming
to our country make us a dirtier country.
He wants to deal with that.
We don't think that's actually an issue.
We find that extremely xenophobic and racist.
He's saying the right things, but for the
wrong reasons.
The issues he wants to focus on domestically
are ones that serve his reactionary agenda,
like stopping immigration to the United States
by Brown people.
And even in the clip, he eventually talks
about how bad Mexico is.
Mexico is not bad in the way that many of
our adversaries are bad.
People in Mexico are functioning primarily
out of desperation and because of corruption
and economic realities, if we really want
to deal with Mexico, we would deal with the
reasons that drugs and people come here in
the first place.
That's not Tucker's view.
He's wrong on this issue, but even Tucker
Carlson recognizes the folly of what Donald
Trump is doing here with Iran.
I wish he would call Trump out instead of
just calling out Ben Sasse and Mike Palm PEO.
I wish he would call out the completely politically
opportunistic nature of this, which is immoral
at its core and he doesn't.
But even if Tucker Carlson pierces the echo
chamber of just a few of the Fox news viewers
that are watching him, this is still a very
good thing.
That being said, I would not be at all surprised
to eventually seek Tucker Carlson kind of
fall back to some kind of mild deference to
Donald Trump in general.
I'd also love to see Tucker, the fiscal conservative
that he claims to be call out that no one
is asking how would we pay for this war in
Iran.
I would not agree with him on all of the things
I mentioned earlier, but I would respect Tucker
Carlson a little bit if he actually called
out the so-called fiscally conservative, right
and said, guys, we can't just talk about can
we afford it when it's healthcare and education.
We've got to talk about it when it's pointless
politically opportunistic Wars as well.
I'm not holding my breath for Tucker Carlson
to do that